exactly I'm you like you don't you don't
realize that [ __ ]
but I think being around that type of
behavior also kind of deterred me from
it because I was in a space where I
could just if I wanted to create
something or if I wanted to do something
I would just do it and it would happen
but now I'm on the other side I felt
like I was begging for a role and it was
it was hard for me well I mean IIIi hear
you and I and I what I hear is the
language that you've created for that
yeah you know what I mean so you've
created you've created a story around
what you your perspective is for me it's
like when you say you're begging for
role no one's you're not begging yeah I
mean you're kind of you're not going
into the room begging if you are you're
going into the room begging for these
auditions and you're never gonna get a
job
yeah for sure you know what I mean you
for me it's like I changed my language
if I were you I think about my language
I would I would never say begging yeah
it's an opportunity it's a a chance to
show what you you're capable of whether
you're right for the part or not it's a
chance to collaborate you know what I
mean so for me it's like you know you
having you just you saying begging and
even when they get and these other young
actors just looking at you they either
one that you don't know if they
recognize you they recognize you from
your social media status or from the
movie they may have seen or just like
you you're you've accomplished something
that's something a lot of a lot of
actors producers haven't quite done yet
which has gone to Sundance which is you
know distributed a film and which has
accomplished quite a bit you know I mean
so if you think of yourself as a mirror
people and other people the mirror you
are reflecting back something that you
see from yourself in the person one
whether it's a good thing or it's a bad
thing or it's envy it so it's admiration
it's all these things you know what I
mean so for me I would say like you know
think about what you're saying and in
the language that you're using that
you're not a beggar you know yeah if you
say you're bigger than you're bigger and
then you're putting you're putting that
kind of energy into these meetings into
these networking's into all the stuff
that the business you know requires yeah
and think about the way you can spot
that as positive spin on it you know
I mean I don't mean the therapy as you
but no I like this because like I think
maybe begging is the wrong term I think
it was more like I just um I was just on
the other side where I I think like if I
wanted to make something happen I could
and then now there's this red tape right
and sometimes - it's is this is why I
think it was really for me to figure out
whether I was going to be an actor or
not and right and when I was watching a
lot of my friends who are actors who I
really admire they didn't have this mind
state that I had and they're like I'm
much like you said like i'ma show you
what I have whether I'm good or not for
this role and I don't know if I don't
know if mentally I could have like
broken into that also - I don't know if
like my headspace was right for the
reason why I did something and when I
started to realize recently was that the
reason why I created that film was that
a spiked you know so after after I
proved my point it was like what next
you know you proved your point so well
are you still gonna continue this so you
got your foot in the door dude so what
are you gonna do with it
and I didn't really think about that
well don't you think it's you know you
live your life do you want man but you
think there's you know you you've again
you've accomplished something that a lot
of people haven't know you know I mean
you can't you got in the door as an
actor you got in the door as a producer
and did you say you wrote it - yeah okay
so as a writer so there's three huge
jobs that you've done you know right out
the gate you know what I mean so yeah
it's almost like it's almost kind of a
responsibility to a certain degree if
you choose to have it it's like what can
I do with this responsibility now that I
have it how can I one if you don't like
doing those things how can you help
someone else who really wants to do
those things break in you know what I
mean
because right for me it's like the what
I hear and I could be completely wrong
yeah is that this is centralized to you
you know what I mean this is that your
feelings and and your pushing and
pushing and then eventually no one's
gonna call you yeah you know what I mean
and the people that admire you too are
gonna hear that you're you you know
you're talking [ __ ] about but you what
you've accomplished you know what I mean
so I mean I I mean I'm just again I'm
just saying I'm don't mean therapy's you
but what what can what do you think you
could do to
to help those do what they want to do
that you don't want to do you know I
mean that you don't know really if you
don't having a desire to be an actor
cool it's like for me is like when I
brought when I first broke in or let me
first go back let me go way back when I
decided so I was going to school in
Nebraska I was at college I was in
college I was a cheerleader in college
and this girl in one of my classes the
short story is she convinced me to move
to Atlanta Georgia with her I just study
acting at this acting class called well
what films with this guy named Jetson
Vaughn who's a producer and is a
longtime actor and he's a back in the
day he was a very he worked a lot as a
character actor a really really really
great teacher kind of gave me the
foundation but as in my road trip from
Nebraska to Atlanta which we drove like
16 or 17 hours straight
I I don't know why but and and I didn't
really know the politics of Latinos in
the industry or people of color or or
the diversity I just knew that I wanted
to so I actually had this conversation
with myself on the drive down is like I
want to get to a place in my career
where I can help open the doors to other
people especially Latino but people of
color people who want the opportunity
this honestly it doesn't really matter
like if it as long as they're right for
the role if they're right for the par-4
cast crew whatever that they want to do
something I want to get to a part point
in my career where I can go I can get
help you get that opportunity you know
what I mean so it's and I'm like by it
by any means I don't I'm not no one
powerful in the industry but I have I've
been able to do that I've been able to
go along man this is this you should
talk to this person about this role I
think he or she would be really great
and then the book and a role I'm like
they have you know either it's done
really great for their career or they've
done something really great and and it's
you know it's been another she's my
stepping-stone you mean
so I guess having said all that is that
I feel like you know especially people
of color in an industry that's
diversifying now that it's been kind of
tough over the years
and it's still a little bit tough and
still kind of like we're trying to make
sure that we're not getting pigeon-holed
and stereotyped and getting a proper
exposure yeah you know what I mean all
these things it's like I I feel like I
feel like and I mean again my any means
I'm not telling you what to do and you
know you got to say I like this live
your life but I feel like you've you've
created an amazing opportunity for you
and people around you it doesn't have to
be the Asian culture you to help those
who have a have a desire to be an actor
or be a producer or a Content writer or
some like that because you've you've
created something right you've created a
world that you have a platform now that
you can you can help people and I'm sure
you're doing it already yeah you know
what I mean but again for me it's like
it's changed in the language how can i
how can I change my language to make
sure that I'm uplifting others as well
as myself you know it means I don't want
to be writing my own story saying that
I'm I'm I'm I am a bit jaded as well but
I'm trying to write my story that I'm
not that I'm trying to help other people
even if that's not myself I mean I 100%
agree I think it's just um I don't think
anybody prepared me for what was good
what this is for sure like yeah I was on
this other side mhm and even the friends
who are actors right now they don't have
like your wisdom you know I'm like
hearing this from you it feels really
good and like I think it is true that
that that language like it's very
negative like the way that I think about
it right yeah it was a very great
opportunity and when I was living it it
felt great you know it felt awesome that
I could create something that was from
my story and you know the person who
wrote a majority of this was this guy
justin chon and justin chon [ __ ]
killed that there was his baby project
worked on it together and you know I I
think like the motivation was kind of
rooted in in a very spiteful way hmm
and so like I don't think I thought
about the positive aspect of what could
have happened after versus just making
this film
you [ __ ] recognize me [ __ ]
[ __ ] out right and so now it's like I
guess sometimes like I think the reason
why I want to create like I still want
to create like films or I continue to
write
a lot of the stuff that yeah like I mean
there's films like crazy rich Asians or
whatever but that doesn't represent my
life as an Asian American it doesn't
represent my story and it's it's you
know it's very small it's like a small
scope of what people share as an agent
American experience sure when we did
this film guk it was about an Asian kid
like me sure yeah I mean they grew up in
Sacramento California grew up in a
predominantly black area and you know it
was very multicultural and it was you
know I wanted to do out things outside
of what people told me that I could be
right and so sometimes when I watch see
I don't even know this is a positive
thing it's like dude like I I want to do
better yeah I mean it's fine like I want
to do better than what's what's what's
out there it's like this is the only
content that people or if sometimes I
feel like people say that this is the
Asian content that Hollywood will take
but I'm like there's more than this sure
let me show you what there is sure so I
don't know like I um I don't really know
what my real motivations stay in this
industry is and like this podcast was
literally I started this as a way just
to help people you know and so that that
in and of itself is great well here's a
couple things that I just thought of is
that one I had to learn it too you know
I mean so quinceanera it's about